hmm not sure we gotta have occasion to
wear this again now
[Applause]
[Music]
the time of the doctor the final story
of Matt Smith's run as the eleventh
Doctor welcome to take to Doctor Who
reviews
starting with Dave the doctor we've now
actually started to overrun with
episodes I have actually done reviews on
before but since they are a number of
years old my feelings have changed and
all those reviews were you know my
opinion after seeing for the first time
and now I have the benefit of hindsight
knowing will came later etc etc etc time
of the doctor this is a really odd story
and I think ultimately the incongruity
and the issues I have with it come down
to the fact that it's doing honestly
probably three or four episodes worth of
stuff in one episode an extra-long
episode granted but still that doesn't
give the leeway that you would need and
as a result a lot of the bits that are
in it feel disconnected and they don't
flow easily one into the other and there
are things that are payoffs for things
that might have had weight if it was
paying off something like that had been
introduced an episode or two ago but
instead it's paying off something that
was introduced the same episode or in
some cases like 20 minutes ago so you
know it doesn't really yeah doesn't
really carried the same weight so what I
say is doing three or four episodes
worth of something I don't mean
necessarily it's crammed three plots
worth of stuff in here but I mean for
the events that are being portrayed to
land properly they needed to be spaced
out over more time and I'll actually
start as an example of that by pointing
out something I really like handles the
Cyberman head the doctor starts out with
that he's just hanging out with and the
TARDIS that he's trying to have
conversations with and
not good at it because it has a very
robotic vine but handle still has a
little bit of personality which I really
like and towards the end we get
basically a goodbye with handles and the
doctor seems choked up about it and it's
a well done scene but it doesn't land as
well as it should as well as it would
have if we'd seen the doctor traveling
with this thing for at least one episode
before now instead it's just oh that
thing that was introduced and has
honestly been in like maybe four scenes
of this entire thing is now dead bummer
I kind of liked it that's about the most
that the impact is on me and given how
much I enjoy handles when he's around I
should feel more when he shuts down but
I don't because the the amount of time
between when I first met him and when
he's gone is too short and there's a lot
of stuff like that the with the head of
the papal mainframe similar sort of
thing they that one I think maybe works
slightly better because sometimes you
can get a sense of history between
characters thanks to the performance and
the dynamic of the actors and the
eleventh Doctor and Tasha LEM have that
a little bit but still I feel like what
was done with her would have paid off
better if we had met her before
the stuff with cars families really
weirdly crammed in like first of all I
don't know why it's there at all like we
had established a tie to earth for Clara
and it was an Jian already now I'm not
stumping frangie and already I should
don't really like them but you have
already established you know earthly
connections and now out of nowhere
you're introducing her family who we've
never seen before and again you're
trying to milk some emotional resonance
out of especially the grandmother and
maybe that would have been there if we'd
ever seen them prior to this
episode and also like oh my am some of
the stuff some of the stuff
it feels crammed in because it needs
more space to breathe to land properly
other stuff feels crammed in because
it's like why is that even there at all
so like for instance Clara gets roped in
with the doctor because she made up a
boyfriend and wants the doctor to come
and pretend to be her boyfriend
as suits just so 90s sitcom it's so
uninventive and unoriginal it doesn't
really feel like it's properly in
character for her at least not as we
understand her or definitely not as we
understand her relationship with her
family because we haven't seen her with
her family that's the kind of thing that
might have worked if we knew more about
her dynamic with her family so that her
doing that would have made sense based
off what we know about the way they
interact but we don't so it's out of
nowhere and it's a lame joke so there's
stuff like that some jokes like that's
kind of fun like the wooden Cyberman
yeah that's that's kind of it's kind of
dumb but like it's kind of stupidly
brilliant so I I kind I actually do kind
of like that but even bringing up the
Cybermen brings up the fact that they
don't really need to be here because
that gag is about their entire function
and that's actually true of a lot of the
extra stuff that's in here there's a lot
of stuff that's here because it feels
like it's here on of obligation first of
all basically anything that ties into
Christmas feels very obligatory because
nothing inherent about the story really
lends itself to Christmas so it and
that's happened before that happened
with stuff like say the runaway bride
but that that episode didn't go so far
out of its way to cram in a bunch of
Christmas stuff it acknowledged hey it's
Christmas and I was
and like had the Santa robots come back
but that was basically it and I said
that if somebody doesn't even really
like runaway bride but I'll give a
credit in on this level whereas here
we've got Clara's family for Christmas
dinner which means we get to crack jokes
about Christmas crackers and turkeys and
things like that we've got the town
called Christmas because okay but it's
all just stuffed in there because it's
the Christmas special and we're obliged
to acknowledge Christmas and the way I
the reason I got on this in the first
place is it feels very much the same
thing with a lot of the additional
villain creatures who are in this it
feels like they're in it because this is
the end of an era because it's the end
of the eleventh Doctor's the end of Matt
Smith's tenure and but they don't feel
organic to this story the weeping angels
have no reason to be here the Cybermen
have no reason to be here the Sontarans
have no reason to be here especially
they have no reason to be here to be
treated like a joke
and I've mentioned this before like look
Strax is amazing but he works as a joke
in the context that he exists in the
jokes should never be he's just an idiot
and these Sontarans are just idiots so I
won't blame Strax for ruining the
Sontarans I will blame this gag in this
episode though because it extrapolated
the humorous tracks and projected it
onto the entirety of the Sontaran race
and we haven't seen them as villains
since so there's all this stuff at it in
and to make another comparison to a
Davies story the end well it wasn't
actually the end of tenants run even but
the end of series four journey's end had
a lot of stuff crammed in it and had
basically every companion that had been
on the show up to that point in it but
it found a way to integrate them into a
story worried made sense that everyone
somehow got wrapped up in it whereas
the whole idea of the reason now these
things are here is because a signal went
out and everyone heard it well okay
first of all you did that already that
was the Pandorica opens so you're
recycling this for no purpose other than
you want an excuse to have other
creatures involved and you got away with
it in the Pandorica opens because it was
a more novel concept of all of these
things in the same place and then plus
the twist at the end it turns out
they're all working together so you paid
it off in that instance Moffat but
you're not paying it off here it's much
more contrived here it reads as cheap I
can see the seams I can see the strings
I can see the hand of the author just
pushing things around to do to allow him
to do and have the things he wants that
don't have a reason to be there other
than he wants them and I'm not saying
authors and writers have no leeway to
just do something cuz they want to but
there is a limit and there's too much of
it in this I gotta check my nose cuz I
did actually write some stuff down
figure out what else I even want to
bring out of the whole naked thing I
didn't find that very funny I it's one
of those jokes that it drags on it's the
source of humor for like five solid
minutes so it if it doesn't work for you
it becomes painful very quickly those
sorts of drawn-out jokes are a gamble
and for me that one didn't work I didn't
realize this before there's a plug for
BBC iPlayer in the middle of this that's
I mean I bear play I guess it's the
their own thing but that struck me as
weird oh I don't like that there right
off the bat in this episode hinting that
oh we found Gallifrey kind of or we
found a way to communicate with
Gallifrey I don't like that the thing
that was set up in the very previous
episode
is already getting tackled one of the
things I really liked about the idea of
Gallifrey is saved but somewhere where
the doctor can't find it was I liked the
idea of that was going to become a
long-term mission for the doctor to find
Gallifrey again
well he's effectively found at the next
episode I mean he doesn't pull it back
into our reality but any tension of will
he find Gallifrey again oh look he found
it huh and and like Moffat tries to milk
that again later on and when I get to
that again I'll let you know what I
think about it but just the fact that it
was brought up immediately in the next
episode that alone already annoys me
additionally they wipe out the whole the
Daleks for God who the doctor is thing
in this one which I'm more I mean here's
the thing about that the amount of time
that passed from one that was
implemented because that was implemented
at the start of this series I I guess
it's slightly better but we'd already
had Daleks this series and I feel like
for that idea that the dogs don't
remember who the doctor is to have
anyway we needed to go at least a full a
full series you know into the next
series before we ever addressed that
again because otherwise you're just
wrapping up something that you
introduced this same series and they did
and also a turn out of that entire
notion had like no impact on anything
and you know between when it started and
now so truly what was the point
Oh Clara dropping that sheaf answers the
daka fancies the doctor since when am i
the only one who feels like that comes
out of absolutely nowhere like I get
that she enjoys traveling with him and
she likes being around him I never got a
fan sees him vibe off her maybe it's me
and the fact that I don't like romantic
subplots anyway that I had an aversion
to it even if it was there but I didn't
see it at all
so that really felt like you came out of
nowhere the whole idea of the silence as
a religious order I'm I'm both like okay
and also a little bit irritated because
as an explanation it's actually fairly
functional works overall in the idea
that the silence themselves those beings
were basically originally created to be
something to confess to and they even
account for madam Kovarian x' branches
being an offshoot that broke away from
the main religion Minh was doing their
own thing that the rest of the church
wasn't cool with so like it covers the
bases but that is all it's doing that
plot point has no bearing on the story
actually being told right now it's only
in there to try and paper over cracks
from a previous story and again just it
feels quite it's one more thing that
feels crammed in because it's not
organic to the story that's actually
being told what's even really even
gotten to talking about yeah give me a
minute I'll get there I actually do like
the 13 regenerations 13 lives twelve
regenerations limit being covered in
here because if if it wasn't talked
about flatly pedantic fans were gonna be
all over it so I like that it kind of
dressed I actually felt like that got
addressed fairly organically and also
like as a thing anyone who is defending
the timeless child on the basis of oh
well they needed to do it so that the
doctor has unlimited regenerations
no they didn't for two reasons first of
all it was all it was a new set of
thirteen regenerations at minimum I'll
come back to that in a second new set of
regenerations a minimum of another 13
lives it took the show 50 years to get
through that many in the first place we
didn't need to add additional things and
beyond that there's a much simpler way
you could have accounted for it oh that
new regeneration that the Time Lords
gave the doctor I guess it didn't have
that same limit on it does it have any
limit we don't know so that there could
still be tension at any given
regeneration that maybe it's the last
one but we don't know we didn't need the
timeless child to fix that there was
something wrong with it yes I'm still
bitter about that thing
okay so let's actually talk about the
story that happens now the story that
I'm going to focus on because like I
said a lot happens the stuff with
Clara's your family happens and stuff of
the Daleks happens and Tasha LEM happens
but where this actually works for me
best is during the period where the
doctor is just hanging out in Christmas
dealing you know year after year century
after century just dealing with the
threats that are there watching the Sun
come up for two minutes and enjoying his
time as best he can bonding with the
people who live there making friends
fixing toys there is a fairy tale
quality to that stretch of the story
that I actually quite like and I think
could have worked and actually could
have even worked as a Christmas special
if that was the bulk of the episode I
think if this thing had actually started
at the setting of the town of Christmas
and was this more ethereal fairy tale
not standard plot structured kind of
story where you know residents of this
town are talking about their experiences
with the doctor and we get to see him
come in and help somebody and you know
maybe in a life saving away maybe in a
very mundane way as he sort of he lives
there but he also kind of Flitz in and
out of their lives and they flit in and
out of his because he outlives all of
them I think something like that taking
up the legitimate bulk of the episode I
would have been totally on board with
instead because it has to share space
with everything else that this episode
is doing that entire segment is
crammed into a much smaller space where
doesn't have room to breathe like so
many of the other things going on and it
has to share space with this other stuff
that doesn't share its vibe I think
that's the big thing for me I like the
vibe of that section but that's not the
vibe of what we open with which is very
almost cartoonish Lisa Comi and jokey
and it doesn't match the vibe of the of
you know dealing with the Daleks it
doesn't match the vibe on the the people
mainframes ship it these things don't
flow one into the other
the doctors actual final moments you
know when he's shouting at the Daleks
that's grown on me I remember not loving
it the first time I saw it that's
growing on me a bit and I do like his
closing moments where he has the vision
of Amelia I actually like that quite a
bit I think it's it's touching and it's
fitting and it and it just works and his
delivery on his little speech is very
solid I also like the trivia fact that
both he and Karen Gillan are bald and
wearing wigs like completely bald
because they had shaved their heads for
movies that they were making around the
same time so if you're standing there
completely bald and head shaved with
wigs on that's just a fun trivia fact
that I enjoy but again the tone and vibe
of that very end that feels again a bit
more in line with the fairy tale vibe
from earlier the vibe that I like the
vibe that I enjoy and what I wish had
been more of the episode and my so my
feelings about this story have evolved I
think I'm a little softer on it than I
was when I first watched it and I think
my specific reasons for not liking it
are a little bit different than what
they were but overall I still find this
to be one of the weaker Christmas
specials one of the one of the weaker
regeneration stories that
it's just it doesn't quite pull together
it's just trying to do too much and I
would actually understand it better if
this was the end of Moffitt Sara and he
was trying to do a blowout for himself
as well as for Matt Smith but it's not
Moffat stayed on so I don't know why
he's feeling the need to cram in all
these additional creatures and all these
plot wrap ups as if he's not gonna have
time to do more of that stuff later I
just don't get it but I think we'll
we'll wrap it up there and I think it's
just important to remember one thing we
all change when you think about it we're
all different all through our lives and
that's okay that's good you've got to
keep moving as long as you remember all
the people that you used to be I will
never forget this day not one line I
will always remember when the council
was me the council's not just me you are
the council now I'm just running the
meetings until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
thanks so much for watching I have a
patreon if you want to support what I do
please like subscribe share this around
and be well
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]